[Music]
welcome back
so in the last lecture we derived the 1d
heat equation essentially using
conservation of thermal energy in a
one-dimensional material a thin metal
rod if you like
and we came up with this partial
differential equation the heat equation
assuming that the material is constant
throughout so it has the constant
diffusion coefficient
or like thermal conductivity
specific heat and density so if this is
one
uniform copper wire these are all a
constant
and this is the diffusion equation or
the heat equation for how the
temperature u of x and t evolves in
space and in time
and if you have forcing you know maybe
this thing is radiating heat to the
outside
or maybe this is a plutonium rod and
it's creating heat through some fissions
throughout some atomic mechanism this
can account for all of those sources
those heat sources or maybe i hit this
thing with a blow torch at some point
this would be a delta function at that
point x as long as the blow torch is on
so we derived this system
and today what i want to do
is show you how you would actually solve
for the steady state heat distribution
given different boundary conditions and
initial conditions so this is really
really important
before i do that
there's something kind of interesting i
like to share with my students when i'm
actually lecturing about this in class
which is the following so we actually
assumed uh when we derived all of these
equations
you know this part of the equation here
at least
that this was an insulated metal rod it
kind of had some styrofoam or plastic
sheath around it so it wouldn't radiate
to the outside
but this big q term here actually allows
me to include the effect of radiation to
the far field
and so if i have an outside temperature
maybe i'll write this in green so if i
have an outside temperature
uh temperature
that is u not
some you know ambient temperature of uh
of the world
then what i have is essentially a q term
that is due to um you know rate
conductance
conduction to the environment
so this would look like u sub t
equals uh kappa over c rho
minus some constant mu times u minus u
naught
okay this is just the linear
heat conduction this is kind of fourier
or newton's linear heat conduction
law here and this is assuming that the
outside u
is such a big heat sink sometimes we
call it a bath
that its temperature doesn't change
because of what's happening uh due to
this this metal rod here okay so we
assume that this outside kind of air or
fluid that this is sitting inside of is
kind of infinite
and its temperature never really changes
uh
even when this is is dumping heat out
into it
now that's kind of a crude approximation
to what actually happens if you have a
hot metal wire and it's hot enough it's
not always just going to conduct with
its uh its neighbor and in fact as it
conducts it's going to create a thin
thermal boundary layer that's going to
kind of insulate it against the
atmosphere so that's what your skin does
if you're just standing still in a still
room and there's not wind blowing you'll
have this kind of thermal boundary layer
around you
and even worse if this is a really hot
uh piece of metal in a really cold
environment then i might actually get
thermal uh convection
it might actually cause buoyancy effects
in the fluid to cause the fluid to
convect
and uh through through fluid convection
through mass transfer
actually move heat away
and that would essentially change this
coefficient mu to be much much larger if
i'm in the regime of convective heat
transfer so this is just an
approximation a very very crude
approximation
but what i like to point out is that um
you know and this is all for the case
where the rod is not insulated so this
is all for the case uh i'm going to just
draw it where
this thing is kind of
blasting out
heat
to its surrounding either through
conduction convection or radiation
and it very very large temperature
differences if the difference between u
and u naught is very large you know like
hundreds of degrees
celsius maybe 100 degrees is a bit too
much
then this u sub t
oh my gosh you should have caught me i
know you can't talk through your screen
but this is a
u x x here that i missed
in my equation i'm actually gonna
rewrite this because this was
a horrible mishap
um
i completely forgot
the diffusion part of my equation
uh kappa over c rho u x x
minus u sorry about that i hope that
wasn't too confusing okay
if i have a really big temperature
difference so for
large
uh temperature
difference
so maybe i have you know the sun you
know a star
that is really really hot and it's
radiating energy away and it's in a very
cold vacuum of space
then this u sub t will still equal
kappa c rho u x x inside of the material
the actual uniform material
but now the radiation to the far field
this m
u minus u naught this constant times the
difference in the temperature between
the object and its environment
and maybe i'll draw here this is my cold
environment
here which is all u not that's space
this is to the fourth power
now that is a big difference first off
this is a nonlinear partial differential
equation now for very large temperature
distribution differences the heat
equation becomes non-linear this is a
nonlinear radiation
and this is called the stefan boltzmann
stefan boltzmann law stefan
boltzmann like the boltzmann that
derived the coarse-grained gas dynamics
equations
and brought us kind of statistical uh
thermodynamics
and this is a non-linear radiation term
non-linear
radiation
so it's really important to know how
these things work if you really really
crank up the temperature difference
between the environment too much you'll
get this non-linear
radiative heat transfer like literally
photons will be emitted to carry heat
away and it will look like this
and so you have to know when your
partial differential equation breaks
down this is a q term that is non-linear
for really really large temperature
distributions for black body radiation
is what it's called
and this is actually really important
this equation here and kind of this
black body radiation equation
was
really important in how we derived and
kind of came to understand quantum
mechanics so there's something called
the ultraviolet catastrophe which
basically says there should be infinite
energy radiated in the ultraviolet
bands it's a slightly more sophisticated
version of this theory
but basically with classical physics it
said there should be infinite radiation
uh in the higher and higher frequency
bands called the ultraviolet catastrophe
and it required
quantum mechanics and uh and plonk and
others to come around to rectify that
situation
there's actually a really really good
youtube video by uh physics girl that
talks all about the ultraviolet
catastrophe and kind of how that brought
about quantum quantum physics
but the point i really want to make here
is that this q function can also include
conduction and convection and radiation
to the environment conduction and
convection and radiation
to the environment
good
okay so for the rest of the the lecture
we're going to talk about how to compute
steady state
temperature distributions using
laplace's equation
so for now let's just assume we don't
have any q
so we're just going to assume that
there's no no forcing it's an insulated
rod and we just have boundary conditions
and
in steady state
in steady state
u t equals zero in steady state
and so essentially what i have is
laplace's equation
which in 1d is really really trivial u x
x equals zero this is uh
laplace in one dimension
and so we're going to solve for the
steady state heat distribution in this
thin metal rod
using laplace's equation
but of course there's something really
important i haven't uh brought in yet
and i think you know some of you are
probably yelling at your screens right
now or you should be
writing down a partial differential
equation
is not enough
i also need initial conditions
so my initial
conditions
uh which would be you know u
of x at time zero
equals some initial temperature
distribution t of x that's an initial
condition so what is the initial
temperature distribution at time 0 when
i start my experiment
and then i also need boundary conditions
boundary conditions
so for example
what happens
what happens at
x equals zero and x equals l what
happens on the actual boundaries of this
this thin metal rod so i know what
happens at a little piece inside but the
boundaries are also important
uh and so there's a few really important
boundary conditions that i want to point
out one of them is fixed temperature
fixed temperature
where you would essentially say
u of
x equals zero
at time t equals some constant a
and u at the other end at some you know
l for all of time equals b so i'm
literally maybe i have some some
electronic you know hardware controller
that measures the temperature here and
adds heat energy or pulls heat energy
out to fix this temperature or maybe i
have this uh sunk in a cold ice bath you
know i've taken a little bit of
insulation off here and i've dunked this
in an ice bath and i put this in a
really really hot bath that are at fixed
temperatures
and we assume that those again are kind
of infinite heat reservoirs that would
fix the temperature
so that's one really important set of
boundary conditions
and the other really important set is
insulating boundary conditions and i'll
talk about that in a minute so
so we have fixed
and then we also have
insulated
and insulated basically would mean that
u sub x
at uh zero comma t
equals zero
and u sub x at l comma t equals zero
insulated just means that there is no
heat flux at point zero or point l i put
little styrofoam caps on this thing and
so there can't be any heat flux any flow
of heat
uh you know in either of these two end
caps at x equals zero or l for all of
time so these boundary conditions are
for all of time my initial condition is
at time 0 for all of space
okay
and so i actually want to show you how
you would solve laplace's equation for
these two
these two distributions here
now laplace's equation
in 1d
is trivial to solve so i'm just going to
solve it down here
so u
x x equals zero okay
we know how to solve this
we integrate it once
and we get
u sub x equals a constant and i'm going
to call that constant one
and then i integrate it again
with respect to x of course
and i get u
is equal to constant 1 times x
plus constant 2.
all solutions
of laplace's equation in one d
you know for these boundary conditions
are going to be of this form because
that's what the equation dictates is
that i can have kind of a linear
function and it can be offset by a
constant uh c2
and so let's look at this for the fixed
boundary condition case so for the fixed
boundary condition case
uh we basically have that u
of zero
at x equals zero has to equal a
so u of zero
which if i plug in zero here it's just
c2
that has to equal a
so we know so this is how we fix our
constants with our boundary conditions
these are kind of arbitrary constants
until we give ourselves boundary
conditions
so
c2 equals a and then if i have c2 equals
a
then when i plug in l equals b
that means u of l
equals
a
times l
plus
c2 and that equals b
and so that means i can solve for c2 so
c2 equals
minus
equals
did i do this wrong i think i did this
wrong
um
oops yeah see shoot i definitely did
this wrong okay
uh easy to fix um not not difficult to
fix okay
i just need to be a little more careful
we okay we evaluated our left boundary
condition to find that our second
constant is equal to a
now we're going to evaluate our right
boundary condition to find out what c
one is equal to so plugging in
x equals l
i get c1l
plus c2 but we know c2 is a plus a and
this equals b
so now c1 equals b
minus a divided by l
so now i've uniquely determined my
second constant and my first constant
just by my fixed temperature boundary
conditions
uh and so we can actually write this out
again we have our little you know thin
metal rod here
and if the left condition is fixed at
temperature a
and if the right condition is fixed at a
temperature
b
then my solution is
u
equals
this c1 um
b minus a over l
times x
plus
a
so it basically lifts everything up by a
and then it's a line that interpolates
between uh temperature a and temperature
b over this length l
so this is the steady state temperature
distribution for fixed temperature and
caps so we've solved laplace's equation
in 1d
and then we used our boundary conditions
to solve for these arbitrary
coefficients to get this linear
temperature profile and if a was bigger
than b it would be the other way
now this is kind of interesting notice
that for fixed temperature
distribution for fixed temperatures on
the end caps the initial temperature
actually is irrelevant for the steady
state
fine final time distribution
so one way you can think about this is
that i have some initial temperature
distribution i fixed the temperature at
the end caps at a and b
and this equation evolves and evolves
and evolves
and we know that diffusion is going to
kind of average out all this initial
temperature
but because my left side is fixed at a
and my right side is fixed at b
it's in the infinite time after all you
know time is passed and i reach a steady
state there's no memory of this initial
temperature distribution it just is
determined by my boundary conditions
now that'll be a little different in the
insulated case so for the insulated case
i still have this exact same condition
here
and again we're going to use our
so now let's say we're still going to
satisfy these boundary conditions
to satisfy c1 and c2
so let's take u sub x
and that's just going to equal c1
and we know that u sub x at the left and
right points have to equal zero
and so that actually means that c1 has
to equal zero that's a really important
property here
is that because of my boundary
conditions being insulating this
constant here is zero
which means that my temperature
distribution is going to be flat it's
not going to have a kant it's going to
be completely flat or a constant my
temperature distribution in this
insulated rod is going to be just a
constant
and to get that constant 2 c2
is just going to be the average of my
initial temperature distribution it's
going to be
1 over l integral from 0 to l
of u of x
0 dx and you could plug in
t of x here
and so my my steady state temperature
distribution for insulated boundary
conditions
now again does depend on my initial
temperature distribution
and i basically just get that my
temperature is a constant which is the
average temperature
the average of all of this initial
temperature distribution
okay so now u
equals this constant 2.
so those are kind of two extreme cases
if i have fixed temperature distribution
then i have no memory of my initial
condition
and if i have insulated boundary
conditions now i don't have this linear
profile it's a temperature as a constant
and that constant is given by the
average kind of heat energy or the
average temperature distribution after
all of these kind of fluctuations uh
diffuse out
so what's really interesting and this is
a homework problem for you
is to start solving this if i have mixed
boundary conditions what if i have a
fixed temperature on the left and
insulating on the right
what if i have
[Music]
what if i have an equals q what if i
have a forcing some steady state forcing
i just always put a blow torch on here
and until the end of time there's a
little delta function here how is that
going to change the heat distribution in
steady state
so again if i had you know u x x equals
q
and i integrate that up twice i'll
actually get
plus
q x squared so i can actually get
parabolic profiles if i have these
forcing functions that's kind of
interesting too
all right so that's a homework
and i guess in the next lecture i'll
probably derive the heat equation in 2d
in 3d and nd which is one of my favorite
things because it really shows you how
gauss's theorem and vector calculus
and kind of
intuition and know-how of physics allows
you to derive really really useful
partial differential equations all right
thank you